there was a time when fortnite was the
biggest game on planet earth but at
least in the esports and streaming world
that time has come and gone recently the
game has had a huge resurgence after
epic games removed building temporarily
then added to the game a permanent no
build mode the question is is fortnite
better without building
[Music]
all right y'all before i get into the
video i have to remind you as always the
like button the subscribe button and to
ring the notification bell fortnite used
to be the most popular game in the world
three million dollar world cups hundreds
of thousands of streamers and everyone
doing this god forsaken dance and since
the battle royale has found its mega
popularity it seems like every single
crossover that could happen has happened
hell ariana freaking grande had a whole
concert event thing in the game now
despite endless celebrity cameos and
jokes at fortnite's expense the game and
the genre it belongs to is still popular
but it's had a dip in popularity dear
viewer let me ask you to reminisce for a
second when was the last time you danced
when was the last time you thought about
default dancing all jokes aside when was
the last time you picked up fortnite
other battle royale games like warzone
super people and apex all have something
that is a part of their core identity
which makes them unique for fortnite
that was always building building was
the backbone of the game and what made
it different not only did it force you
to find better loot you were able to
make defenses or even better position
yourself by building the whole game was
balanced around building but for many
people that was also fortnite's most
frustrating feature see not only did you
have to be good at the usual shooting
mechanics but you also had to be
insanely good at building you had to be
quick and smart to outplay your
opponents and eventually reached a
meadow where actual children just like
became architects like the final circle
at the end of a lobby was more of a
senior art student thesis presentation
than 1v1 if you catch my drift to put it
simply building just really overtook
shooting instead of it being a feature
that helped it stand out from other brs
it became the game itself like we were
in simcity but with the release of
chapter 3 season 2 on march 20th epic
games brought the mode that we have been
waiting for five ever
fortnite zero build
wow
so still the same battle royale just no
building and extra movement like wall
scaling fortnite's twitch viewership
spiked dramatically when the game mode
released with some of the og streamers
making a return tfu was one of those
whose career was built on fortnite he
loved the update and gave his super
official stamp of approval ninja said it
brought back the og fortnite vibes and
said it's the most fun he has had in
years and when tim is not dying from
fall damage it also seems like he is
having fun this change was so refreshing
because building became too intense and
too advanced for some people
myself included i can shoot fine but
admittedly i was being outbuilt and
outplayed by people who arguably had a
lot worse aim than me but could simply
position themselves higher by building
themselves to the high ground high grand
advantage gets them every time so when
this new game mode was announced people
were stoked it is a bit of nostalgia a
bit of release the fortnight i literally
grew up playing in high school has had a
bit of a return where building isn't
everything in fact in this game mode
it's nothing and when it came out people
were having fun fortnite is back man i
don't want to hop on here and just
criticize it immediately i really just
want to take some time to enjoy the fact
that like i enjoy playing this game
again i feel like it's so quick to hop
on like the what that what's going wrong
train i just want to destroy it dude i
just want to turn off my brain and shoot
people people were clamoring for this to
be a permanent mode and epic made our
wildest most desired dreams come true
fortnite zero build is now a permanent
mode for us casual non-architects who
simply want to shoot but the builders
still have their regular battery owl to
go to it's funny because removing the
most vital part of the game is maybe the
best thing they could have done the
building was getting boring liz did you
just admit that you suck yes i did but i
was not the only one who felt that way
about building jade king wrote for the
gamer.com pretty much how i feel i
walked away because i wasn't willing to
learn building nor did the game offer
compelling ways to do without getting
absolutely trounced fortnite is infamous
for vaulting and debuting guns grenades
and utility but no matter what they did
the building met advancement was unable
to be stopped but now it's almost like
epic has invited me back personally
we've been told that it's okay that we
fail to become master builders with that
said i'll know for all you sweaty battle
royale gamers out there that when it
comes to esports building is not going
anywhere one of the biggest complaints
from the streaming community when it
came to fortnite in building was that
because of skill-based matchmaking the
tifus and ninjas of the world who were
good but always wanted to have fun would
get farmed by 16 year old cracked g fuel
kids now if you want to be the next buga
you can still do that in arenas and in
the normal battle royale mode but if
you're trying to have some fun without
the whole world constructing the eiffel
tower experience you can do that in zero
build even the mogul himself ludwig and
a 100 000 partnership is now bringing
ludwig mondays featuring fortnite for
all to enjoy as i'm writing this
fortnite's viewership on twitch is
really comparable to valor and apex and
cs go two of which had major
competitions going on the point is
fortnite is back because of this mode
the game is now a lot more welcoming to
everyone our master architects and our
casual running gun folk and that spells
huge news for fortnite's future the sky
is the limit and we do not even have to
build to reach it
you want to know how many hours i played
in high school at night seven when like
this was also during the summers too
when i really picked it up because i
like had time and wasn't like being a
student but like i would religiously
play that game wasn't good i was getting
better but i would like play with my
friends and like i would for hours
just grind that game